what is happening there reject nation uh
hey
whoa
so
i was about to edit a video
and then i was on social media
i don't think john knows about this yet
oh no even though john gets all the
credit for everything that's right
because i do most of everything
theorizing it all mapping it out editing
researching you know it's all john
everybody all day every day uh-huh oh
john yep that's what today's video is
about
[Laughter]
opening banter done all right guys
listen
whoa okay this is gonna be huge what i'm
about to go into
sony just confirmed
that there's three spider-men in the
most like this is the most obvious hint
i think they've ever done in case you
guys don't already know uh we'll we'll
talk about it there's this empire
magazine cover had spider-man on it and
we'll go through like the details on
there i'm gonna get the big thing out of
the way right now because on this cover
it does say stuff like spider-man no way
home old foes new suits no rules
marvel's multiverse madness begins which
is really exciting and we know what
that's all indicative of but then empire
magazine put out the tweet and sony
pictures uk john tell me what that is ah
that is a response with three spider
emojis in it there are three
one
five oh geez three
whole thing is the art the empire
magazine they are covering how this is
essentially like the spider-man
multiverse and while they have already
revealed several of the villains they
haven't revealed them all and we haven't
gotten any confirmation yet
about the three spider-man the fact that
sony p they know what they're they're
messing with they know what they're
doing and they would not troll like that
if they weren't actually in it you know
they are teasing to me
that is the most indicative thing that
they can say currently without it just
being revealed in a trailer that there
are three spider-men in this movie
especially when you have the empire
magazine covering the multiverse they
even have this like great promo artwork
here i'll show it on camera which some
people might uh presume that this image
of all the spider-man in there to to me
what is that dimension called the mirror
dimension the mirror dimension ah that's
why you're the expert john that's why i
am the person people come to for marvel
that's why you're the expert because i
didn't know that you did it's you know
what you should read a comic book greg
or maybe watch an mcu movie jeez do it
second [ __ ]
second bit's done i don't know i'm kind
of like flabbergasted right now you're
catching me in a moment of
john
literally said john we just stopped here
we gotta we gotta talk about this i
don't have any clear thought processes
here but yeah like but in this cover uh
as a lot of people are probably already
done videos on it it's a beautiful cover
to behold obviously he's got this like
sick ass new suit here
uh i love the look of it he's supposed
to have i think
16 new suits
yeah yeah
a few for every act of the film
yeah
yeah because the run time of this movie
is supposed to be two and a half hours
so every 30 minutes we'll get a brand
new suit up is what we're going to be
doing yeah um and then of course you got
the doc ock tentacles here you got the
pumpkin bomb as established you got sand
in the corner
obviously that's rhino they're hinting
because he kicks up a lot of dirt when
he comes in oh it is man yeah got some
electricity you know what i was thinking
since they haven't they haven't
confirmed with the sixth member of the
sinister six is in this movie i was
thinking that for rhino what they could
do for a little bit of redemption to
have people more interested in him being
here i don't know if you guys know this
you guys might not know this i don't we
might be the first youtube channel to
address this oh boy in the amazing
spider-man 2 the ending shots those are
in the amazing spider-man 2 trailers
what yeah so people were like a little
disappointed when that was the ending
shot of the trip hangar of the movie so
what if rhino was in it and then you do
see the continuation of that scene
that'll be fun and they bring back that
little boy who was in the crowd dressed
as spider-man but that's tom holland
they keep the same actor
okay yeah we'll go with that no they
keep the same act no it's fine no that's
what you do man you you interrupt and
you improvise with a new bit but you're
the master john
you're the know it all king
of guiding the ship ahoy
captain you know if john was manning the
titanic it wouldn't have hit the iceberg
because all i'm saying
yeah we would have left late and we
would have missed the ice cream
would it come in handy
yeah and then of course you have like
some of the uh yeah
this cover looks like it's straight out
of the what if opening credits to me
especially like the shark glass and then
you got the yellow
timeline stream thingy that you see
teased in avengers end game when uh
the ancient one is talking about that
with mark ruffalo or it could be part of
the
spell cast runes yeah show up when he is
doing this about to make everyone forget
about you know who what peter parker's
identity really is
you also have scream the return of ghost
face oh yeah on here howard the duck
hallelujah
fearless star comes out fighting
fighting spider-man fighting spider-man
and cat woman is the other member of the
city yeah
perfect if anything i what i really love
is this actual this empire artsy cover
here i think that is so cool i just wish
you didn't say empire on it
that's the one thing keeping you from
printing it out big and putting it up on
the wall yeah because you have the
pumpkin bombs and you got the dr
octavius tentacles you have the eye of
agamotto here with the time stone in
there which is causing upheaval of
confusion
what wasn't it destroyed
in avengers infinity war this doesn't
make any sense not in a multiverse movie
it doesn't and then you have bart
simpson's hand popping up here
making a fist going yeah finally whoo
and you got even a couple spider-man
logos
yeah man different iterations of the
spider-man logo like it's i i really
feel like that the cover is cool and
what they kind of dive into is pretty
cool but a lot of it is still very
familiar what were like it had it didn't
do anything all that revealing yes if
anything the sony pictures uk
reply to empire magazine is way more
telling than any of that
i envy them so like you know that the
people at sony are sitting around in
their tower just giggling with glee
watching us write over tweets and things
like that that was uh that was nuts to
be like what did they just do
i don't know man they either did a big
old hint or they just messed with us and
it just means they put three emojis
instead of one or they were just like
holy man was that this is the third
spider-man movie yeah jeez one two three
makes sense
oh
dang
dang dang dang
anyway yeah movie's supposed to be two
and a half hours right now yeah which is
a perfect run time eternals was two and
a half hours and that did really well uh
for helping that movie breathe all their
packing into that movie and i think this
movie yeah i think we used three hours
that they wanted well yeah i mean
because with the sinister sixth and
three spiderman you got at least nine
main characters eternal got ten main
characters yeah we gotta make it thick
all right guys well what do you guys
think about what i mean more than the
magazine what do you guys think about
this is this is what's confirmation
because it certainly reads that way
all right guys we'll catch you guys soon
thanks for being here